let's just talk a little bit more about
the the cognitive stuff uh because it's
again it's that now it's not just the
economic stuff that's finally leaking to
cnn uh here's cnn's van jones on what's
going on with biden as david axelrod
says and he's come out and put his name
on and he said look this is a person who
if they win will be closer to 90 at the
end of their second term than 80. and
therefore these are very fair questions
joe biden said these were fair questions
the last time when he was running
so do you have these questions
well uh
i think everybody is looking very
closely now uh i uh when he does when
biden does well he does really well that
gun speech he gave he was perfect it was
it was powerful when he does badly when
he stumbles you get nervous and you
wonder is it just a stutter is he tired
or something else there and so i think
that people just looking i mean honestly
i think i think a lot of democrats are
like if if this guy's ready to go we're
behind him but if he's not ready to go
he should let us know i think
ah i love van jones he uses so many
words to say nothing uh liz
it is leaking into mainstream media i
mean i know you've been talking about it
on your show we've obviously all been
talking about it but once it sort of
breaks that airlock then everyone starts
talking about it right
yes however i would warn conservatives
across the country this is something
that conservatives have been a little
naive about in the past when the
mainstream media finally picks up on
something that we have been talking
about for years or something that's very
obvious to everyday americans don't
don't give the the mainstream media the
benefit of the doubt this does not mean
that they have seen the light this does
not mean that they are red pill this
does not mean that their motives are
pure this means that they know that
they're going to get a shellacking in
2022 and they're already looking for
something to blame they've started
putting into motion their plan of how
are we going to explain to the american
people when we lose in in november we're
not we don't want to blame our policies
because we stand by our policies we
don't want to blame um everything that
we want to continue because uh because
they want to continue it so this is a
deliberate plan they have not seen the
light they are going to blame
joe biden after the 2022 elections
because they never planned to run him
again he was obviously old he was
obviously just the way to shoehorn
radical leftists into the administration
into the swamp into the administrative
state so that they could bring someone
like mayor pete who has a very innocent
very very boy next door look but who's
actually very connected to marxism
including the legacy that was passed
down to him by his father um this is
something like i said conservatives
should not fall for this because this is
only a strategy that's being picked up
by the radical left probably also
because they see polls that show the
american people are concerned about this
and they want to seem like from their
high perch from their elite purchase
like they relate to us yeah i love that
point liz because it's like one of these
things every time these people who get
everything wrong say something remotely
not insane we always fawn over them and
it's like no we've got to stop doing
that just because bill maher is three
years late on everything you got to stop
cheering him on for it until he can get
to the end of the road